ultimate pizza party is back it's the
Las Vegas pizza Festival it Returns on
Saturday November 12th at the industrial
event space and here to tell us more is
Vincent Rotolo uh he's the owner of good
pie good to see you buddy welcome back
to the show thanks for having me we're
so excited the festival is back it took
off because it's over the whole thing
it's back this year what do we have
going on this year it's incredible we
got the women in pizza coming in we have
over 20 of the best pizzerias in all of
Las Vegas Tony gemignani from Pizza Rock
John Arena good pie you know it's it's
gonna be amazing we have the pizza
trucks coming out too we have four
different trucks going there we have
tattoos we have Scott tattoos and pizza
acrobatics live music Pizza acrobatics
you can go to Pizza tattoo and walk
around and just there's beer there's
local breweries there's big dogs are
going to be there huddle it's gonna be
great now you're bringing something very
special to the festival what are you
guys making today we're doing the upside
down Grandma Pizza upside down grandma
Yeah it features is a really amazing
organic tomato sauce right so you put
you put like 18 ounces of sauce on this
pizza High degree of difficulty so it's
the sauce is going to cover up the
cheese on this and then we finish this
pizza with what we call you know they in
the restaurant when someone wants the
ricotta flowers on the pizza they have
to say make it nice make a knife so if
you say make it nice
we're gonna make it nice so we got this
one hey when did you start making pizza
at what age yeah I was 12 years old wow
I was in New York City and making pizza
was kind of like a rite of passage in my
family my brother was making pizza at a
local pizzeria and so I always made
pizza but I didn't actually sell a pizza
until I was 41. you like a pizza
hobbyist I was like I was like you know
those guys on the weekend who like work
on their cars doing pizza or pizza
instead of a Gearhead you're a pizza so
check this out look at this look how
pretty that looks so we're gonna make
these nice stunning and you guys too at
Goodbye you guys have vegan options if
you go to the actual shop itself you
have everything right we do we're
bringing in New Moon vegan cheese from
Brooklyn unbelievable Quality Cheese
there can you see this you guys this it
looks delicious now what's the cost for
the pizza Fest the pizza Festival
tickets are now the general admission
tickets are 75 that includes unlimited
tickets but
I'm gonna share something with you and
this is not for the viewers at home it's
just for you and your friends there's a
promo code okay okay it's I love pizza
okay if you go to pizzafest.com and you
put the promo code I love pizza you'll
get a discounted ring but that's just
for me that's just for you it's for me
yeah don't don't tell anyone me and my
friends all right cool and my friends
are everyone that's watching yeah
everybody thank you so much we're gonna
go to break it I'm gonna eat some pizza
Festival we'll be right back